So my wife and I
have two young children.
And like many of you,
we are terrified
about what the worst impacts
of the climate crisis
are going to be for them in their lives.
Do we honestly have a plan that's specific
that's achievable, that's actionable,
that's going to allow us
to reduce emissions at scale
with the speed that's necessary
to respond to the catastrophe in time
to improve the quality
of life for our kids?
We've decided to focus
and devote our time and attention
to the challenge of greening
buildings in America.
And I'll tell you a little bit about why.
There are 125 million buildings
in America, coast to coast.
These buildings are where we cook
and eat and work and pray
and raise our kids.
A lot of us spend almost 90 percent
of our time indoors in buildings,
and these buildings
are powered by fossil fuels.
We burn coal and gas at power plants,
we burn oil and gas in buildings.
This is a furnace that produces
hot water and heating.
This is in an apartment complex in Harlem
that we visited back in 2014.
And I remember visiting it,
I was a little worried because we could
smell gas kind of, leaking.
And a few blocks away,
a few weeks before this visit,
an apartment building
had a gas furnace that exploded.
It collapsed the entire
apartment building,
it collapsed the apartment
building next door,
and eight people died.
So I remember looking at this boiler
and taking a picture and thinking,
“Get me the heck out of here.”
(Laughter)
So because fossil fuels
power our 125 million buildings,
it's 30 percent of emissions,
30 percent of American emissions
are tied to our buildings.
And there is no actionable path
to responding to the climate crisis
without going building by building
and greening all of the existing
buildings in America.
So I'm Donnel Baird,
I'm the CEO of BlocPower.
We are a technology company that focuses
on moving buildings off of fossil fuels.
We want to make buildings smarter,
healthier, greener,
and we want to do that by making
buildings 100-percent electric.
We're here in Detroit.
Detroit is learning how to rip
fossil fuel engines out of vehicles
and replacing them with smarter,
all-electric engines.
We want to do the same
thing for buildings.
We want to rip out
all the fossil fuel equipment
and replace it with smart, green,
all-electric equipment.
And we want that equipment
to be powered by electricity that’s clean.
Stanford professor Mark Jacobson
has written a plan for all 50 states
to be powered by wind,
by hydroelectric power, by solar,
state by state, so that our entire
grid can be clean.
I got focused on the dangers,
the perils of fossil fuel systems.
Growing up as a kid with my family
in a one-bedroom apartment in Brooklyn,
we didn't have a heating system
that worked in our apartment
building in Brooklyn.
So when it got really cold in the winters,
my parents, sometimes they worked nights,
they would tell me, "Look,
if it gets too cold, light a match,
turn on the gas oven,
open up the oven door,
and don't forget to open up a window
because heat's going to come
into the apartment,
but so is carbon monoxide,
and we don't want you to suffocate."
Then they'd go to work.
And millions of Americans
across the country
heat their buildings this way
in the winter and worse.
But it's not just the low-income buildings
that are super dangerous
with fossil fuel infrastructure.
Recent studies indicate that gas ovens,
gas heating systems in our home
leak benzene, they leak methane,
they leak nitrogen dioxide.
There's so much nitrogen dioxide
emitted into American homes
that it causes about 13 percent
of chronic childhood asthma.
There's so much methane
leaked into our homes
that it's equal to the emissions
of 500,000 gas-powered vehicles.
And benzene, benzene is a carcinogen.
And the latest studies from Stanford
indicate that benzene
is emitted into our homes,
it spreads throughout the home,
it lingers, we breathe it in.
And it actually can be worse
than breathing in
secondhand cigarette smoke.
And so for any parent,
the thought of our children sleeping
and breathing all this stuff in,
it's horrific.
But good news,
it's 2023.
We don't live in ancient Mesopotamia.
We no longer have to dig up
dead dinosaurs from the ground
and burn them in our buildings for energy.
We've got options.
This is an electric induction oven
that uses electricity and induction
power of magnets.
It’s hyper-efficient, it’s safe.
The finest chefs in the world are starting
to use these ovens and systems.
They can boil hot water
in less than 60 seconds.
Pretty awesome.
And one of the new technologies
that I'm really excited about
is the cold climate heat pump.
Cold climate heat pumps
are like a silver bullet
for reducing emissions in buildings.
We can now do things that we could not do
five years ago because of this technology.
They use electricity and refrigerant
and compressors to pump hot air
into your home in the winter,
to pump hot air out of your home
during the summer, to heat up hot water.
But most importantly,
it allows us to fundamentally unhook
buildings from fossil fuels.
We can unplug all of our
buildings and homes
from fossil fuels entirely
due to these systems.
So let's go back
to my building in Brooklyn.
We now have a mix of technologies
that we can install in our building:
solar panels on the roof,
high-efficiency lighting,
electric hot water heating systems,
electric heat pumps
for heating and cooling,
the electric oven.
We can make these buildings all electric.
If we're in Detroit or LA or in Houston,
one of the cities where people
love their cars,
we'll of course, install some
electric-vehicle charging stations.
We'll have some backup battery systems
because all three electricity
and energy grids
are collapsing under the weight
of heat waves and the climate crisis.
But we can electrify buildings.
Now, is it simple?
Is it easy to electrify buildings?
No, there's challenges and opportunities.
We have to solve the finance problem,
we have to solve a workforce problem,
we have to solve a data problem.
Electrification can cost 10, 20,
30,000 dollars per building.
And that's not affordable
for the average American.
But what we can do is most Americans
can afford to buy a home on their own.
And so we have a mortgage.
And so we studied the mortgage market
and found ways to amortize and spread out
the upfront cost of building
electrification over 15 years
so that the monthly payment is affordable
and lower in some instances
than what families pay for fossil fuels.
We have a workforce problem
in that, like Europe,
there's a shortage of skilled electricians
and technicians across America
to deliver on these projects.
Mayor Eric Adams in New York City
has asked us to train and hire
3,000 vulnerable
and low-income individuals,
ex-offenders, gang members,
military veterans with PTSD,
formerly homeless folks,
to train them in building electrification.
We had a gang, a street gang
kind of come to us and say,
"Look, if you guys hire us
and give us jobs,
we will shut down our street gang."
We had a crew of workers who had been
locked up in Rikers Island,
our New York City jail,
and we trained them, we hired them,
we took them back to Rikers Island,
They installed solar panels
in the parking lot.
We have a data problem.
Every building is unique,
like a snowflake.
So in order to make sure
we have the right size
of the electrification equipment
for that building,
to unhook it from fossil fuels,
we have to collect data
and make sure we specify
and recommend the right equipment.
We've been working with the Bezos Earth
Fund to aggregate all of the data
on all 125 million buildings
across America
so that families can search
for their address,
get an electrification work plan,
hand it to a local,
well-trained electrician
who we've trained and hired.
These are good jobs
that can't be outsourced,
so that every family has access
to the data that they need.
We've recently started working
with Ithaca, New York,
where Cornell is located,
and San Jose and Menlo Park.
These are cities that have committed
to decarbonize 100 percent
by the year 2030, in six and a half years.
So we're going to go building to building
and move each building
off of fossil fuels
and make them all-electric.
So we've got six and a half years,
but there's dozens of cities
across the country
where we're working with partners:
Portland, Oregon,
Denver, Atlanta, Chicago
to electrify buildings at scale.
Electrification is possible.
It's not simple, it's not easy,
but it is possible.
And what that means is
if we can electrify one building,
it means that we can electrify
a whole block of buildings.
If we can electrify a block of buildings,
it means that we can electrify
a neighborhood.
If we can electrify a neighborhood,
it means that we can electrify a city.
And if we can electrify a city,
that means we can electrify a country.
There’s a saying:
you have to be the change
that you wish to see in the world.
By doing this, we’re going
to create great jobs.
There’s going to be massive economic
and public health outcomes.
But we also are going to inspire
cities and countries
around the world to electrify.
And we’ll be able to look
our children in the eyes
when they ask us and say
that we're doing everything we can
to reduce emissions at speed and scale,
to fight the most damaging impacts
of the climate catastrophe.
Thank you.
(Applause)